this is actually been going back the
past four or five years that since since
the financial recession the Great
Recession you've seen luxury cars bounce
back a lot stronger than the sale of
regular cars in kyle stock who is a
senior editor at bloomberg businessweek
has written the story about it and this
year in this week's issue and he shows
that for example just premium brands
alone including cars that sell for the
you know about one hundred thousand
dollar range like a Porsche or a
Maserati the growth in those brands is
up twenty five percent year-over-year
and the growth in you know all car
brands is only up about four percent and
that's bet basically then what we're
looking at the past three or four years
the ultra luxury cars like the super
Lamborghinis the Rolls Royces the cars
that cost you know 400 500 thousand
dollars they're just soaring and in fact
the ultra luxury car producers can't and
won't make them fast enough wow you know
because there's so many more
millionaires they're 211,000 people and
they want to buy 30 million dollars
there's almost a million people that
have more than 10 million dollars and
they want to buy these things so how are
they how a regular car manufacturer is
hardly dealing with this then well you
see a lot of regular car manufacturers
for example Ford look Alan Mulally did
his best to to get rid of all other
brands besides Ford he wanted to focus
only on Ford but they couldn't let go of
Lincoln because they needed to have one
luxury brand General Motors is doing its
best to revive and boost sales of
Cadillac most luxury car manufacturers
are trying their hardest you know Nissan
for example is totally focused on
Infinity even if it's losing money for
them almost everybody wants to hold on
to some kind of luxury brand if they can